should we should we talk about how the
media is sympathetic to the extremists
oh my gosh yes
oh yeah check this one out oh from
buzzfeed
these two lawyers face up to life in
prison
for allegedly burning an empty cop car
the federal case against the lawyers
colin mattis
and uh uruge ramen is a stark example of
how the trump administration is cracking
down on black lives matter protesters
they made uh several mistakes writing
this article
oh tell me so the first thing they said
is we admit it
this is black lives matter done
every every statement of support every
every banner at every football field
every knee bent on the field
is now represented by two people who
were giving out and throwing molotov
cocktails
whoa that was a mistake antifa separated
black lives matter from the violence
even though i kept saying we know
these people they're yelling black lives
matter right there's a lot of cross
culture going on
so thank you buzzfeed for giving us the
facts that these people who are going
out and burning everything down are in
fact
representatives of the black lives
matter movement and there it is
the other mistake they made was that i
think it was in the tweet
so i wonder if it's included in the
article yeah here we go they go on and
bring up how these people are immigrants
immigrants immigrants immigrants
immigrants
i got a question buzzfeed why does it
matter
that these extremist arsonists these
people arrested
on charges of uh being of you know arson
and uh
you know other i guess i don't know what
else was charged we'll be into it
but what what does their [ __ ] their
crime have to do with them being
immigrants
you know what this sounds like to me
this sounds to me like these countries
that these people are from
are not sending their best oh no
oh what have you done to propaganda
oh no buzzfeed buzzfeed are you are you
making pro-trump propaganda oh my
goodness
you say that the children of immigrants
are are
are that somehow correlates buzzfeed you
don't not like
trump do you listen listen it's an
assert
it's an absurd notion but they're trying
to garner sympathy by saying they're
immigrants being prosecuted and instead
they're saying firebomb arrests and
immigrants which are completely
unrelated
they're extremists it's their political
ideologies nothing to do with who their
parents are i'm sure
in fact their parents worked very very
hard to get here and are probably very
upset with them
let's read a little bit of this and see
what they have to say because
the tweet they put out it all seems so
sympathetic to these poor black lives
matter supporters
protesters who uh there's there's a
photo of them in a car holding molotovs
oh wow i mean it like it looks like them
i'll put it that way i gotta be very
careful because we're dealing with it
you know innocent until proven guilty on
stuff the ny is what buzzfeed writes
the nypd van on a brooklyn street was
banged up and empty
a battered steel shell with shattered
windows and a mask of spray
paint shortly before 1am on saturday may
30th
the fourth straight night of nationwide
protests against police brutality a
molotov cocktail set ablaze
a surveillance camera perched outside
the nypd's 88th precinct down the block
captured the incident
including a tan town and country minivan
at the scene
around 10 minutes later officers pulled
over a vehicle fitting that description
colin ford mattis 32 was at the wheel
and aruj
ramen 31 was in the passenger seat
officers found a lighter a tank of
gasoline and a bottle stuffed with
toilet paper in the back seat
ramen and mattis were handcuffed and
transported into holding cells at the
nypd headquarters
two of 23 people arrested in brooklyn
that night for actions connected to the
protests against police brutality
they're facing life in prison and based
on what buzzfeed just wrote i kind of
think they'll get convicted
so for burning uh an already blown out
van they're gonna get life in prison
did it say it was already blown out yeah
they said their windows were shattered
it was spray-painted it was a hot oh
sure sure yeah for throwing molotov
cocktails it's still
state property it's not it's not it's
not about the damage to the vehicle
it's about people driving around with
molotov cocktails and throwing them
really
i mean what life in prison what if what
it's an act of terrorism
yeah they're doing it for a political
cause i don't you know i don't know it's
an interesting question because i'm not
sure i like the idea of crimes on top
like motive crimes
but what if there was somebody like in
the car
they wouldn't have known no that's their
core because it was some other woman i
believe who threw a multi-vetted car
at a van full of that person should get
maybe charged with
like life in prison i think for trying
to kill a bunch of people the issue is
we like you're gonna go out with molotov
cocktails throwing them
it doesn't matter if you were like don't
worry i'll do my best not to engulf
someone in flames you can
charge someone and arrest them charging
with life in prison or charge them and
then
you know give them life in prison and
then let them out also yeah they could
they could get parole or something if
they change their way i mean
45 years uh or life or whatever they're
saying that's that's
that's really harsh but uh i wonder
i wonder if the reason they're doing it
is because
setting an example maybe dude maybe and
then maybe they have to
yeah check this out check this out they
say the case against ramen and mattis
took a different track
because the incident involved an
explosive device a specialized unit of
the nypd officers
and fbi agents called the joint
terrorism task force
formed in 1980 to root out threats to
national security spearheaded the
investigation
within hours of the arrest before
brooklyn prosecutors had even begun
writing up charges
fbi agent kyle johnson submitted a
criminal complaint in federal court
and federal prosecutors informed local
authorities that the u.s attorney's
office for the eastern district of new
york
was taking over the case no one knew at
the time
but this was one of the early moves in a
widening federal crackdown against black
lives matter protesters across the
country
whoa whoa whoa whoa they just made a
very big mistake oh another one
oh yeah antifa is out the window all of
this is now
overtly black lives matter interesting
that's
it it's not anti-violence it's i've been
thinking it's black lives matter the
whole time i mean not the whole time but
it's not like they're mostly peaceful i
mean they're mostly peaceful
but a lot of these protests mostly
peaceful yeah they've just been blending
together in my mind i can't tell which
is which people go out there they dress
in black
some people have really good intentions
and some people are blowing stuff up but
they're all out there together
honestly if you have good intentions
you're completely overruled by the
people who just takes a few to have bad
intentions to
totally guilt by association when you're
proud like that dude
these people are getting locked up
forever look i mean look at this
they say when it came to ramen and
mattis and the alleged crime of burning
an empty and already damaged police
vehicle
the u.s attorney's office brought
charges so severe
they carry a mandatory minimum sentence
of 45 years in prison oh wow
and a maximum of life a potential
punishment
one former federal prosecutor called
ridiculous another called out of hand
and a third described as an extreme
tactic to send a message to other
protesters
maybe that's the case sending a message
i don't know man i'm not a fan of making
examples of people
giving individuals harsh penalties so
that other people are deterred no the
crime is on the individual and the
individual should
should face appropriate crime and
punishment like dude you could argue
that we're
we're at war right we're i mean we're at
war overseas 100
in iraq afghanistan um and this is like
a domestic
like george washington would execute
this is a story that i've read i don't
know 100 a lot about it but if someone
would try and like throw down their
weapon and not fight he'd have them
killed he'd execute them george
washington yeah commander of a military
if their soldiers start to refuse to
fight or do whatever
you have one killed to show the other
ones if you do that you're gonna die i
don't know about that so that sounds
brutal yeah you have to otherwise the
troops will stop fighting
and then you lose the war and everyone
dies yeah but if you do that then morale
drops to zero no that's a way to spark
morale
because morale's dropping so you gotta
whip everyone back into shape that's not
good morale talking about
authoritarianism
have you have you seen the meme the beat
the beatings will continue until morale
improves that's
hilarious no way dude this is about
raising morale raising morale the
populace having faith in the police and
the
in the judicial system this is sending a
message for the election
this they they want this story from
buzzfeed the the
all of these all of these law order
types want everyone to know you go with
molotovs
during a riot they're going to lock you
up forever
i'm inclined to agree with ian here
because it's not necessarily about
increasing morale for the people but
it's about increasing confidence in the
system
and in the feds and in the fact that the
rule of law will actually come to
fruition
unlike in portland and showing that the
power lies
in the government not you right so when
it when it came to
the the washington dc the white house
protest
where they cleared out all the people in
front of the white house you guys
remember that yeah
and then they were like trump did it for
a photo shoot like trump didn't do it at
all
some people said yeah what they were
like trump didn't do that
i mean i just saw the most ridiculous uh
so the official story is that
trump had nothing to do with the
clearing out of the protest there were
two things that happened
there was a time time frame set on when
the protests were going to be cleared
out and bill barr said he's the one who
told him to clear it out
trump then did a photo shoot that's
those are the facts okay
so the left is making the assumption
donald trump ordered it for his photo
shoot hmm
trump might have had no idea okay
someone might have been like oh they're
they're
that you know the protesters are going
to be leaving and then trump was blocked
let's clear him out because the
president's going in trump's probably
watching fox news and he's sitting there
and you know he's eating his
mcdonald's and i'm not i'm not i don't
mean that to write in in a disrespect
disrespectful manner he literally does
this
and then someone said uh mr president
your seven o'clock photo shoot uh in
front of the church oh okay
but and he gets up and walks regardless
peaceful protesters were like
smoke smoke grenaded out to get the
president in for a photo shoot
no or they were they were knocked out in
some sort weren't they weren't they got
they were thrown out with some sort of
violent
dispersal the police dispersed them yeah
but it's an assumption that it was for
trump's photo shoot
okay just coincided with his photo shoot
that's so i don't even want to say that
because al
all we can say is what we know the
protests got cleared out
trump then took a photo shoot in front
of a church the night the i think it was
the night before or the night before
that
they had set fire to the famous church
was it st john's i think john's yeah
historic presidential church that you
know right across the street they set
fire to it
and uh trump doing this photo shoot i
believe there's a good possibility it
was an intention it was intentional they
cleared out the protest so trump could
do this
i can't prove that and of course the
media will claim they can
they say trump did it for this reason
you don't know what trump's motive was
he probably had no way he
it possibly had no idea but uh i'll tell
you what he did
taking that photo proved to the country
if they wanted to they could snap their
fingers and shut the protest down
yeah that was the point he showed two
things the church stands
it was not burned down and two when the
protesters are here and we say move you
move
that's what that photo shoot meant
that's more messaging then
right so you know in this regard
lawyers facing very serious charges is a
similar thing
the government is in control but the
rioters they weren't rioting though
those people were peaceful so if you're
in a peaceful protest and the government
says we say you move you
move you don't what are you supposed to
do as a peaceful protester
you move because they have the tanks and
then you file a lawsuit
again and they're the ones that are
going to do the lawsuit for you are the
ones that perpetrated the crime
no the police aren't the ones who deal
with the lawsuit well it was federal
cops wasn't it
and the lawsuit is your private lawyer
going to a court to challenge the
executive authority
the court is under the rule of the same
people that no
the reports are an independent branch of
the government yeah hypothetically
i mean sure but it's supposed to be
trump you know the executive
the executive appoints judges who then
get approved by
legislature so it's supposed to you know
there's checks and balances but
that's the way you do it if the if any
one branch steps out of line then you
you you file
a a claim i i don't don't ask me how it
works if the courts
you appeal the courts i guess you know
that's what you do the court is the
ruling say i appeal and then it goes
supreme court then stops
but if the if the cops are something
wrong you comply
if the cops like there's there's one
dude who's arguing for the right he's an
activist in milwaukee he argues for the
right to physically attack cops who
tried to arrest you
calling it defense uh oh yeah yeah
said he said it it was a quote from some
site i'm not familiar with the site
but it was called like boston review.net
and this guy said
if if a cop is violating your rights you
have a right to defend yourself from
unjust uh unlawful arrest
well well who determines whether the
arrest is lawful because nobody wants to
get arrested and nobody thinks they're
being legally arrested
they're they always yell things i have
not been read my rights therefore the
arrest is illegal
and then what you're going to swing at a
cop yeah right they don't have to read
your rights dude
so i think it's i think it's about
messaging i do thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you